for the reds it's sonny gray been a guy
that we've said it before we'll say it
again trying to find himself his words
on the fly 1-0 pitch and this ball
ball's lifted high into the air but just
to the left of dead central under it is
naquin he's got it catches made side
retired it's a one two three first
inning for sonny gray and he used just
eight pitches to navigate the first
three hitters in the marlins order
where's tyler naquin
has picked it back up and that is a
10-game hitting streak that will reach
the right field corner naked on his way
to second base he's thinking about third
on his way to third base in with a
triple
tyler naquin you talked about hitting
the ground running
well how do you hit a triple you hit a
triple running out of the box
you see as this ball is hugging that
wall
a little trouble in right field with
sanchez but
tyler naik went thinking three bags
as soon
as that ball leaves his back and now
nick casianos will stand in
that's a fair ball that'll play naquin
ostiano's on his way to second base and
with an rbi double on the reds have the
early lead
see a hanging slider right there
nick castellanos can just hit
say that about a lot of these hitters in
the lineup
they are fun to watch
is team leading 31st double one to
nothing early and joey votto stands in
rounded to first bottled booted by
aguilar and everyone is safe castillanos
on to third
and the red's still in business here
first and third one out
now kyle farmer up
eyeball center field
well deep enough to get castiano's home
from third he tags it up
and the reds have a two-nothing lead rbi
number 46 for farmer jesus sanchez
hot shot to india
nice play
second high hopper bad bounce of the
game and india handles it nicely
jonathan india has been so impressive i
think that was a little self-persevation
either catch it or it's gonna catch you
almost knocked him down one two three
one two three so far for the reds right
hander he will face the bottom third of
the marlins order
and the o2
swing and a miss
first strikeout for sonny and when
you're throwing strikes early
guys have a tendency to expand here's
the one two and fastball in the outside
corner the dagger call of strike three
by john campaign and a one two three
inning nine up nine down from freddie
gray with del rojas who flew out the
right fielder nick castiano's his first
time up
i really like the footwork
of mike moustakis over there at third
base
he's got happy feet just look like sonny
gray the last two hitters he was trying
to make a perfect pitch now it's time to
lock it in aces loaded one away
ryan anderson at the plate
first pitch fly ball
shallow left center field who wants it
it is naquin here comes the throw and
the runner holds what a throw it was
they keep the runners right where
they're at and now lewis brenson's
now the old to
at pitch miss
gray leaves them loaded
two-nothing reds
and now kyle farmer will come to the
plate
green and right field
bottle rounding second base he's on his
way to third sanchez has trouble in
right field and that will allow farmer
to reach second base
kyle farmer has been so good
just quality of bad after quality at bat
see sanchez try to cut this ball off
little trouble digging it out back to
back strikeout for hernandez when he
needed him the most they're going to
intentionally walk tucker barnhart bring
up sonny
gray and a cold strike three eliezer
hernandez what a job to get in and out
of trouble in the fourth inning one man
out here in the fifth and the batter's
alex jackson
2-2 pitch swinging to miss struck him
out
down on strikes alex jackson
two away
see you later
an easy fifth for sonny gray
tyler naquin of the play he's had it big
night already
naquin with the drive to right
and that bad boy is gone
number 16 for naquin
and a three-nothing reds lead hands
hands and hands my oh my here is nick
castiano so heaton back up and did that
get castianos it did and castillanos
with a stare
back towards hernandez
i don't know of any intent on that
particular pitch but
i wonder why it's happening so much next
set is because we rake
you guys want to get inside on us the
last three times that nick castianos has
been hit by a pitch
and is next at bat vato has followed
with a home run each of the last three
times that costianus has been hit by a
pitch and is it four make it four
[Applause]
i think joey just said to nick
maybe they hulk you again hopefully they
won't hit you but maybe they will
gray has really turned in some kind of
outing hasn't he so far
stock is to his left sets and fires
picked by vato
that was in-between hop right there
joey did a really nice job of going out
and getting that ball
go get it joe
two down and here's jorge alfaro
back to
gray it's another one two three frame
seven
strong shutout innings
from sunny gray right hand hitting
shortstop up against the right-hander
lucas sims
two balls two strikes
ground ball fair ball that's going to go
down the line and get toward the corner
alex jackson is being held at third
so it's a double for miggy row and the
marlins have two in scoring position
here in the eighth
it's that slider
ball is working outside corner
miguel rojas with two strikes is just
trying to make contact with it wasn't
trying to do too much and that ball just
hugs the third base line
batter is
jazz chisholm
1-0
and jazz hits one a ton to right and a
line drive home
run marlins are right back in it after
the three-run shot from jazz chisholm
junior well jazz has found the power
stroke over the last week he has been
really sitting on that back side a great
time to find that swing again a couple
of men on a fast ball in and a big
three-run home run to rikers that runner
at third is inconsequential means that
the tying run is at the plate
and that is alex jackson
from the belt to the plate the one-two
pitch
twing and a miss he struck him out
gibbons blows a fastball right by alex
jackson
and that's it reds hang on and win it
5-3 over the marlins tonight at great
american ballpark the reds have won the
first two